hello Internet welcome back to Conan 360 the amazing camera technology I personally invented with a little help from my friends at AT&T over here this summer conan 360 returns bigger and better than ever when my show touches down at comic-con in san diego imagine all the science fiction superheroes and fantasy you love up close and personal in thrilling conan 360 and if that's not nerd tastic enough conan 360 is now virtual reality compatible so put on your favorite VR goggles and get ready to experience late-night like never before that's right all the action all the stupidity beam directly into your eyeballs as virtual reality Wow it's like I'm with me doing a shell I can see inside my own mind and into infinity and Bay's Conan 360 your irradiating in it now [Music]